hello Kermit the Frog here Muppets Most
Wanted Muppets most wanted is to return
of the Muppets actually a sequel to the
return of the Muppets that being said I
liked the return of the Muppets levira -
let's give this one a shot but in
Muppets Most Wanted there is this Kermit
look-alike his name is Constantine he
has a mole on his face he replaces
Kermit he's travelling around with the
Muppets and Ricky Gervais becomes their
manager but there's a scheme to do a big
heist now and Kermit's locked away in
some Russian slammer never good never a
good place to be just sounds very cold
now we have musical numbers and Muppets
and musical numbers and people and
Muppets and musical numbers and is it
enjoyable yeah it's enjoyable I actually
didn't enjoy this one as much as the
last Muppets movie I thought the last
Muppets movie had more pop-culture
references this one still has
pop-culture references I just felt the
last one had it in the way that it was
updated for a modern audience but like
this movie hearkened back to other
Muppets movies of old you know when they
died but I still enjoyed the movies
always fun seeing the Muppets the
musical numbers there enjoy their catchy
[ __ ] at first you're like holy crap a
lot of musical numbers and a couple of
them you're like yeah alright cool you
say it like I do like cou couple of
really good pairings in this movie -
these dudes I thought made the movie
they had the best jokes the best
chemistry a couple of their jokes as
shown in the trailer and that bummed me
out but the rest of it that really
flowed with these guys and I really
enjoyed Kermit story-arc at first I was
like it was like x-men - I mean I really
like x-men - but you know Xavier is gone
for most the movie you're like let's
Hermits the Xavier and he's gone for
most of the movie he actually has his
story going on in the present and it
cracked me out I actually enjoyed the
prison story more than the actual
Muppets doing their thing with the
impersonating Constantine muppet Kermit
thing however the drawback of this movie
I felt like it was made for more of a
young audience springboarding off for
the last one especially the last one I
was like yeah adults can watch this this
one adults can still watch it and there
are jokes that are made for adults but
in the end I was like I feel like kids
would like this more than adults and
even then kids will be like I don't I
just like fuzzy Muppets this movie one
me with a series of chuckles nothing
made me drop on the floor dying laughing
like I'm holding my stomach like oh my
god I can't live without that joke I'm
gonna remember that joke forever
but it was a series of chuckles like
funny few minutes later I was like few
minutes later I was like
and so you kind of rinse and repeat that
the best part about this movie for me is
that it actually poked fun at the
concept of sequels or like yeah they're
not as good and why are we doing this
the small part of the overall scheme in
the movie but that's what stands out in
my mind
come on the end Muppets Most Wanted is
enjoyable it's cute it's chuckle worthy
I didn't feel like it was as good as the
last Muppets movie you're not a Muppets
fan by now this isn't gonna win you over
I feel like the last Muppets movie was
like if you're not I'm up it's been give
it a try we'll see this one's like if it
hasn't won you by now isn't gonna do it
but it's a good time for families and I
walked out of the movie actually
enjoying it so I will say Muppets Most
Wanted is a good time no alcohol
required so the Muppets Most Wanted have
you seen it what did you think about it
or if you're them up his fan what's your
favorite Muppets movie whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]